[Music]
hello everyone i would like to welcome
you to the kaijan digital insights
webinar on how to streamline your
variant classification workflow with the
human gene mutation database or hdmd
my name is mega balanado and i'll be
your host and moderator for today
i would like to introduce our speaker
for today dr milena gaddis malena gaddis
is a clinical field application
scientist at kyogen digital insights
with previous experience as a variant
interpretation scientist
and now i will hand the presentation
over to milena thank you
thank you mega
and thank you all for joining today as
we talk about different ways that hgmd
can help streamline your variant
classification workflow
i'd first like to go over the overview
of what we're going to be discussing
today
first we're going to talk about what the
human gene mutation database is hdmd
and then also some advantages of hgmv
professional
and then i would like to walk you
through some examples and use cases that
i've encountered previously as a variant
scientist
that have really
been
good illustrators of how hdmd is a
valuable tool to help with variant
research
and then as megan mentioned we will have
a q a session
so first what is the human gene mutation
database
it is an expert curated database of
human germline mutations from
peer-reviewed published journals
drawing your attention to this figure on
the right
you can see an analysis between the
content in hdmd
omim and clinvar
and
nearly 60 percent of the clinvar entries
at this point in time are found within
hdmd this remaining 36 000
is likely not an hgmd because clinvar
does not necessarily require users
who are submitting their clinical
assertions about a variant to
have specific guidelines for
evidence to support that assertion
and so
we like to say if it's not published
it's not an hdmd
you can also see that
hdmd has quite a bit of content
that is not available in either omim or
clinvar
and so really it's a great tool
if you're asking the question
does this human germline mutation cause
disease
i'd like to note that hdmd is for
germline mutations only not for somatic
many of you are probably aware that
there is a publicly available version of
hgmd
i'd like to just take a moment and talk
about some of the advantages of having a
professional version
one of the main ones being that with a
professional hdmd version
there are quarterly updates
where information is recovered from more
than 2000 different journals and this is
done manually
by
genetics experts who are actually
reviewing all of this literature
in this table on the right i have some
statistics between
uh the second quarter release of this
year for hdmd
and the third quarter release
and you can see just between the two
quarters there's quite a bit of content
um thousand you know twenty thousand
thirty thousand variants that are added
just within one quarter
and i'd like to note that with the
publicly available version
the content is three years
out of date and so
you can see
having this
professional version you get the most
up-to-date
clinical information for these variants
the hdmd entries will include the first
example of the mutation where it was
published in the effect
and additionally there may be
more reports
pubmed entries that are either
functional studies
or
publications that indicate alternative
phenotypes
information that may be useful to the
user
and so there are a couple of ways that
you can access this information
first off with the advanced
with the hdmd professional version you
have advanced search capabilities that
are not necessarily available with the
public version
you have availability to search by gene
or mutation you can do phenotype
searches
and you can look at these mutation
overviews for specific genes to get an
idea of the number of
mutations by variant type
also
there is an availability of a
downloadable version of hdmd
professional
so if you prefer to have the data in tab
delimited files
or a mysql relational database that's
also available
so now that we've talked about
what hd hgmd is i'd like to now move on
to some examples where hdmd has been
particularly useful
as i've done variant research in the
past
specifically talking about you know
doing the research of a variance
clinical significance
some ways that visualizing variants
through hdmd
can provide information about
the allele of interest that you're
looking at
ways to identify genes associated with
specific phenotypes
and then using some of the advanced
capabilities to design an ngs panel
and so my first use case is for a
variant
in the gene that has kind of a
difficult
naming scheme it's got legacy and
alternative names that can make research
kind of difficult
this gene is serpent a1 and in this use
case you know a variant scientist would
be given this variant to look over
and to research
and given the hgvs the human genome
variation society nomenclature for this
variant
i want to present what a workflow might
look like
so for this variant the user may go to
clinvar first
and because you don't necessarily want
to take the entries in clinvar at face
value
you dig a little deeper into the entry
and you see the associated literature
for that variant
however there's no mention of any
alternative names
uh or other schemes within this clinvar
entry
and so you're looking up this serine to
codon 6 to change to leucine
and
so you pull up this literature
information that was associated with the
clinvar entry
and when you investigate
this pubmed you see that within this
paper the only serine to leucine change
is happening at codon minus 19.
you also notice that this is somehow
also associated with something called
p-i-z-rexum
so at this point you're not seeing any
mention of a serine six leucine
so you may move on to the gene review
for serpent a1 where you indeed confirm
that alpha a1
alpha-1 anti-trypsin deficiency is the
associated phenotype
and you get a little bit of background
information about the gene you see that
variants were initially described based
on electrophoretic protein variants with
the prefix
pi denoting protease inhibitor
so essentially they would
add this pi
in conjunction with the name of the
location where this variant was
identified and this was all before they
knew that serpent a1 was the associated
gene
and so you have
not only what appears to be like a
legacy name
where the codon is different but you
have
this different alternative naming scheme
based on
the location of where the variant was
found
but still at this point you're not quite
sure that you can confirm
that serine 6 6-leucine is in fact the
same variant as the serine minus 19
leucine
you take a look at the omim entry
and you kind of get the same information
the same literatures associated
the same names are given
however you still don't have any
confirmation
that this is the variant you're looking
at you suspect it is but to be certain
at this point you would have to do
additional digging
to confirm
that the information you're finding
is relevant to the variant you're
researching
i would propose going to hgmd as your
first step in your variant
classification workflow because it's
going to provide you that background
information
and save you time
that you where you don't need to go and
research these historic or alternate
naming schemes
so here i'm showing a browser view of
the online version
where i've searched by gene serpent e1
and i've looked at missense variants
and within the first entry i see
the variant i'm interested in in serine
six leucine
and conveniently hdmd has a special
column
that describes the legacy change and you
can see that there's an offset by 24
amino acids
explaining why
you're seeing this minus 19. it was
probably part of a translocation signal
or something and the original
people studying
started counting 24 uh codons downstream
and so
i have con confirmation and i can click
on this hgmd accession here
to view the variant entry and in this
variant entry
again i get confirmation that the
associated disease or phenotype is alpha
one anti-trypsin deficiency
hdmd considers this a disease causing
mutation
again i have the codon number
and the legacy codon number available in
this view
and i have the primary literature report
for the first time experiment was
published as well as an additional
report
and so at this point i can be confident
that when i'm talking about
this serine six leucine
it's the same thing mentioned in this
primary literature
because the geneticists who are
reviewing the information
and updating
the content within hdmd
will not associate literature if there's
any ambiguity
they will in fact follow up with the
authors of the publication if there's
any question
so they've done that
background digging for you saving you
time
so that you can move forward with your
research
i have another example i'd like to show
in another gene
this time you're looking at the gene gne
and you're looking at an arginine 297
glutamine change
and in and i'd like to break out of the
presentation and show you a live
example
of how you could do this type of search
within the online version of hdmd
go ahead and log in go to online
and you're first brought to the home
page for humd where you can see
the current version
the contents and any important
announcements or updates
and so there's a number of ways i can
search i could search by gene
if i wanted to look at all the variants
within the gene g n e
and then narrow it down by missense
i could do that
until i find the one i'm interested in
i'd like to show you another way where
you can more directly pull up this
information
here in this mutation search you could
search by the codon if you have the hdmd
accession you could directly look
dbsnp i'm going to use the coordinate
so using the chromosome and coordinate
i can paste it in here
and important to remember that there's a
drop down where you kind of specify how
you're searching and you also want to
specify if you're doing this by
coordinate which genome build and i'm
working in hg38 so i'll go ahead and
i'll submit my query
and it directly pulls up
my variant that i'm interested in
and so if i wanted to i could also click
on the gene symbol and get that same
uh
spectrum of mutations that i could find
by searching this way
how i could link out to dbsnp
i'd like to review the accession
and so pulling up the succession
i say that the associated phenotype is
cellularia
and again
the hgmd entry is fighting this is a
disease mutation
i don't see anything in the codon number
about a legacy
naming scheme
and so then my attention is then taken
to
the literature there's a couple of
different
papers the first one being reported
in a portuguese
girl who had the clinical biochemical
and molecular characteristics
additional papers were added because
the reviewers found that there was
good information useful information
that they added
and i want to draw your attention here
to the comments
and the notes something that i have
found particularly helpful at many times
is that reviewers will add
these notes that clarify things for
example
we're looking for something at codon 297
but within the paper it's indicating
that it's an arginine 266 glutamine
again another
note in another public about another
publication
it's reported the same way and it gives
ensemble transcript
also helpful is many times the the
comment will tell you kind of where to
look for the variant so if it's only
listed in the supplemental though
they'll point you in that direction
and
it it also shows the value and having
someone manually look at the information
and they're not just reviewing the text
the body of the text they're able to
look at you know graphs and figures
uh they look at you know supplemental
table supplement information
and then they kind of point you to where
they found that key piece of information
for the variant
and so here you know that there's
um a reporting scheme on a different
transcript than the one
you've been given
and so hdmd the web version has this
additional predicted hdbs descriptor
feature
where it will list all of the rest seek
transcripts the htvs descriptors
as well as the ensemble
and so you know you can you know match
it up that 815
and from here it gives the c dot that
you can confirm
that the 797 g to a
is actually
this 266 q if you translate it to
amino acid
and so here's another example where
uh you know first reviewing the hdmd
entry
gives you key insights that will help
you as you continue with your literature
review
now if i were to go and look for
additional literature
i would know that there's a possibility
it could be reported a number of
different ways and so i need to be aware
when i'm doing that search and how i
form that search
and so
you know at this point we've talked
about how hdmd can help you with your
variant research and save you time along
the way
and so moving on i would like to talk a
little bit about
some of
the use cases for
visualizing this data and for
downloading the data
so
many people
when they download the hdmd
vcf file
will will
the vcf from hdmd
and annotate their variants and um one
you know use case for doing that is that
you know sometimes when you do
sequencing you'll get a large list of
variants and you want to narrow down
to look at those that are most likely to
be clinically significant
and so you can filter by things like a
little frequency or quality metrics but
you could also annotate with hdmd
and filter down
that way as well
to to come up with a smaller list
of variants to look at in more detail
so
another use case for that downloadable
vcf is for visualization purposes and so
why is this helpful
sometimes you want to see what's in the
genomic neighborhood what we like to
call the genomic neighborhood and
this could be
visualizing a vcf track for your variant
of interest
and being able to see if there are
entries within hdmd that are at the same
codon
and that are marked as
disease mutations or supposed disease
mutations
and having this visual representation
for many users is quite helpful
other times you may find visualization
helpful if you're looking at a
particular
region of a gene for example if you're
at the three prime end
and you're looking at frame shifts and
if you have something that's past
the boundary for nonsense mediated decay
you need additional evidence from the
literature or functional studies showing
that
that last part of the protein has
significance if it's
cut off and so being able to see
visually an hdmd track
showing other reported
disease mutations in that location will
point you to some of that evidence
another use case that i find helpful
is having the hgmv track loaded to help
confirm that my secondary
analysis is accurately calling or
describing variants
so i have a case here
that i've uploaded into the ucsc genome
browser
it's within the apc gene
and i'm at a region where there's a
little bit of repetition with this agag
motif
and
my variant of interest is here in purple
and you can see that there's a little
dash on top followed by the ga on the
bottom
indicating that you have an assertion
of a ga
and
i can see by loading the hdmg track on
top
which is what all these bearings on the
top are
in blue
i have
a
an insertion of a ga
that's nearby or in the genomic
neighborhood
and
so
as a as a person you know
reviewing this variant and
maybe examining the bed file or the band
the reeds
i might be suspect i might suspect that
this insertion
is in fact supposed to be
called here
a few bases away
downstream
because in repetitive regions sometimes
there can be
changes in
how it's represented in the vcf versus
hgbs
and so i would know to follow up
maybe with finger confirmation
to make sure that this is in fact the
variant i want to look at
and that it doesn't need to be
altered in my secondary analysis to
actually reflect
something that's been reported in the
literature
as a disease mutation
so you can see how
having this visualization
makes
this type of analysis quick
and just briefly i'd like to go over
kind of how
you'd go about that process of uploading
so when you have a professional license
for an hdmd download you have a number
of different files that are available to
you
um
i'm highlighting here
the the vcf the zipped vcf in hd 38 also
available in hd19
so you would just download that
and then
many individuals will use integrative
genomics viewer rgb or the ucsc genome
browser
a lot of times personal preference
just to give you an idea of what an
upload of this bcf looks like in 9gb
i've loaded it here
and then oops
i've
blown up the
information here
so this is information parsed from the
vcf file
and so
you can see
the gene and the phenotype
the hgvs nomenclature
maybe
the vcf format is not supported as well
in igd it has this little percentage
but you can get the key information here
i tend to prefer using the ucsc genome
browser
i like that
you can see the
the nature of the
variant change
so you can see
if it's a deletion or if you have an
insertion
you can also see if you have you know
like gtt
large cmvs
um
it provides just a little bit more
information
and so this is kind of what
the parsed information from the vcf
would look like
we do have versions that are
specifically formatted
for the
ucsc genome browser that provides the
full entry that's available with our
genome tracks product
just as an fyi
and so i have some additional use cases
that i'd like to actually show
so i'm going to move out
powerpoint
and
my first one
i'll pull up so just briefly it's
relatively easy to upload a vcf
within the ucsc genome browser you would
go to my data
custom tracks
and then within here you would add
custom tracks and then there's just a
quick upload
and this you can save your session so if
you don't want to have to reload every
time
you pull up the information it will save
all of these settings and configurations
so i have here in the in this apc
variant that i initially showed
um
here's my variant of interest in purple
there's a dash at the top so an
insertion of an ag
and this repetitive region
and so i can load my my reads file
and
determine if my variant calling pipeline
needs to be adjusted or if this is in
fact a novel
variant in the individual
another use case for
having this information in this visual
format
is if you're doing like variant
classification
according to acmg guidelines
one
piece of information or evidence
here i have my variant of interest in
the gene pah which is a g to t i can
quickly see that at this same location
there have been disease mutations
reported in hgmd
for g to c and g to a
and so this is something that as part of
acmg you can
use as a piece of evidence if these are
then shown to be
pathogenic that tells you that you know
this codon has some sort of functional
importance
and and so having this kind of
neighborhood view
to see kind of what's upstream or
downstream can be very helpful at times
and
so you know now that we've talked about
some of the applications for using the
downloadable vcs
i'd like to move on to some other use
cases
here
for
when you may want to identify genes
associated with a specific phenotype
you know if you're
more on the research side
and you're interested in
discovering what genes are associated
with the phenotype
in this case you know bipolar disorder
within the online user interface
we have the ability to search by
phenotype
so then all i would have to do is i
could do a boolean search where
um it will pull in the actual entries
with the term bipolar disorder
and search within hdmd phenotypes
and i can quickly
find
for the associated bipolar disorder
phenotypes within hdmd
a list of genes
that have you know associated literature
indicating some sort of relevance or
impact
with this phenotype
and so this is a good place to start if
there's you know additional
places i want to take my research i have
this list to follow up on
another use case
might be
to utilize the content within hd d
to design a panel maybe based on
phenotype maybe i want to design a panel
for cardiomyopathy
so in this case you would do an advanced
search
and i'll actually do kind of a
demonstration showing the search but
but what you would get is a list of
the
variants within hgnd
that are associated with cardiomyopathy
oops sorry about that and so i'll skip
out now and do
and show you kind of how i did that
search
so i went to advanced
and within advanced i went to
nucleotide
substitution
plus
and within this page
i'm i'm interested in
searching by disease phenotype
but you have a number of different
parameters that you can include in your
search if you wanted to search by
functional elements
um
maybe if you're doing research and
you want to look at variants within
known transcription factor binding sites
that could be particularly useful motif
search
if you're looking for specific you know
supply experience or regulatory regions
i kind of want to look at it all
so i so i've highlighted
my output file the information that i
want to receive back
i want to get that mutation variant db
snip
and i have specified my genome build
and so
i'm just going to specify cardiomyopathy
and then hit submit
and at this point it pulls up that table
and i can actually download
bed file that you can then load into
ucsc
and then you can visualize across all of
the associated genes with cardiomyopathy
the known variants so if you then wanted
to go and design targets for a panel
you can make sure they're covering all
of these associated hdmd entries
you can also click here to save it as a
text file
and so then you pull this up
probably looks better in excel but you
have all of
this information
that was brought forward
which is displayed here in nice tabular
format but you have that option to
export it and save it
and so
hopefully you know i've been able to
show
that hdmd has a lot of utility for for
varying classification
and
um
and that it can really speed up your
process by giving you that information
about historical or legacy names
different transcripts
so you can
quickly get through your literature
search and get to your answer
and you know there's different ways that
you can use the data
to visualize or to annotate
to help with other aspects of
analysis
and
you have up you have many different
options for
uh searching for this information you
know by phenotype
um and in that advanced search where you
can actually export and then
move on to help design a panel based on
a phenotype
so
um you know thank you for your attention
and for listening and i'd be happy to
take any questions at this point thank
you for that informative presentation
milena
with that let's straight away jump into
q a i see a lot of questions coming
my first question would be how often is
hdmd updated
so htmd is updated on a quarterly basis
okay
second question
is there an applaudable vcf with more
information included from the hdmd entry
yes so with a download of genome tracks
which you can
license
you have a number of different files
that are specifically formatted
for
upload into ucsc
and there's different ways you can view
the hdmd you can view by like phenotype
and um
by disease mutation or functional
polymorphism
so so yes that is definitely available
great
next question would be
does hcmd provide information about
genomic polymorphisms in genes
yes so
for a polymorphism
to
be
included in hgmd
there is some sort of literature
evidence
showing
a link to disease
or a phenotype
and
so
polymorphisms can be added to hdmd
okay we have some time left to take a
few more questions
next one which genome build is used for
hdmd
so hdmd has been
updated for hd 38 and most of you know
the information is presented that way
however there is still support for hg19
so that you can
also see that information if that's the
build you're using
okay
why are there articles for a specific
variant that have not been captured in
hcmd but can be found using other search
tools such as google scholar pubmed
etc
right so so you will note that
there are just a few articles shown and
and really the aim of hdmd is to show
the primary report that first report
where the variant is um
published in the literature and
the additional articles are really only
added if there's something new
or important that they add for example
an updated phenotype
or
functional evidence
talking about you know protein structure
and and so the goal of hdmd is to not
necessarily return
all of the possible information
available for a variant but to give you
that
key background that's important
and so so that's why you're going to
find
those key pieces of information rather
than every single publication
for that variant
next one
do we have to pay extra to download the
data from hvmd
if you already have hdmd pro
yes so the hdmd online version and the
hdm
hdmd download are both part of different
licenses
and so
you can consult with a customer
representative to
see what the price difference may be to
add the download to the online version
of the license
okay we have three more questions
in hmd does it provide the information
or evidence of its variant
classification
so hgnd is technically not classifying
variants in the terms of acmg
but they will give
an
annotation of a disease-causing mutation
or a dm
or if it's suspected to be a
disease-causing mutation it'll have dm
question mark
and so the evidence
is within those publications
and the curators who are reviewing this
evidence
always err on the side of adding
something
rather than leaving it out if there's
any question about its association with
disease so that in future publications
come out
this variant is kind of flagged for
further
review
so that it can be you know revised in
the future as more evidence becomes
available
great
should we be refreshing vcf's upload
from hcmd to ucsc every quarter
yes so every quarter
when the new version of hgmt
professional comes out there will be
substantial additions
and new uh mutations that are added to
the database
so i think it would be a good idea
to upload
the new vcf each quarter just so that
you're reflecting those new additions
to hdmd
and the last question of the session
is uh html integrated into qci if so is
it the full version of hmd or the public
version
yes so qci is qci
hydrogen clinical insights interpret and
it's
a software that assists in variant
interpretation
and so with the license of qci interpret
um you are able to see the full hdmd
entry for
the version for the variant that you're
looking at
so what this means is if you wanted to
search for nearby variants
those hgmd entries wouldn't necessarily
show up as part of
qci interpret you would need the
additional license
but for every variant in your vcf that
goes through interpret
for which there's an hdmd
entry you will be able to view that
entry as part of
interpret
all right
before we conclude i would like to thank
our speaker dr melina garris and most of
all you our audience for your attention
we hope this was informative and helpful
however if you should have any remaining
questions please do not hesitate to
contact us we are here to help you
this concludes today's session on htmd
we look forward to hosting you in future
kaijan digital insights webinars
have a pleasant rest of your day thank
you
you